in this video you're gonna learn how to
write a quadratic in standard form by
completing the square and we're gonna do
an easy example a medium example in a
more challenging example go ahead and
pause the video and see if you can do
these on your own but we're going to go
through them together the form that
we're trying to get them into is this
form right here notice the vertex H and
K the a involves a vertical stretch or
vertical shrink and the first thing we
want to do here is we want to take a
look at the quadratic and we want to
rearrange it so that we can complete the
square so the first thing that I
recommend doing is moving the constant
this number over here to the other side
of the equation so I'm going to subtract
3 from both sides so that gives us Y
minus 3 equals x squared plus 4x now
when you look at a quadratic notice it's
in this form here ax squared plus BX
plus C you want to take that number that
comes in front of her to the left of the
X that's the B value you want to divide
it by 2 and then take that quantity
squared okay so in this case you can see
the number in front of the X is 4 we
take 1/2 of 4 you can do that work on
the side if you want 4 divided by 2
squared so 4 divided by 2 is 2 2 squared
is 4 out of thin air I'm adding 4 to the
right side of the equation so to keep it
balanced I'm going to add 4 to the left
side so this gives us Y plus 1 equals
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to write this as a binomial
squared so it's going to be X plus 2 the
quantity squared it's always going to be
1/2 of this B value so if this is minus
4x i would write minus 2 here okay we're
almost there now the last thing is I'm
going to subtract 1 because of what I
want to do is I want to get Y by itself
so y equals x plus 2 squared minus 1 and
you can see the vertex is going to be
negative 2 negative 1 remember the one
group with the X it's going to have the
opposite sign because this is X minus H
so the vertex negative 2 negative 1 and
you got it so for number two now a
little bit more challenge here here and
what makes us more challenging is that
we have a coefficient a number in front
of the x squared term okay so our a
value is not 1 it's 3 in this case same
process though what we want to do is
think of f of X as like Y okay
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
move the constant the number to the
other side by doing the opposite adding
one so that gives us y plus one equals
3x squared plus 12x what I'm going to do
is I'm going to factor out that
coefficient to three we're not taking
the greatest common factor we're just
factoring out the three out of both of
these two terms here so we have 3x
squared plus 4x plus blank okay
equals y plus one so now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to complete the
square so we're going to take B divided
by 2 and square it so 4 divided by 2 is
2 2 squared is 4 now the mistake that
students make is that they say all right
you know Mario I headed 4 to the right
don't I add 4 to the left well the thing
is to see how this 4 is inside of the
parenthesis so actually out of thin air
we're adding 3 times 4 which is 12 to
the right side of the equation to keep
it balanced we have to add 12 to the
left side ok sorry with me so far so now
what we have is y plus 13 equals 3 and
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
factor this quantity in the parenthesis
and it's going to be X plus 2 squared
very similar to this previous problem so
it's always half of that that B value if
this was minus 4x that would be minus 2
blasting is to move the 13 to the other
side to get the Y by itself so you can
see our final result is 3 times X plus 2
squared minus 13 and our vertex is going
to be at negative 2 negative 13 remember
this one in parentheses is the opposite
sign okay last example see if we can do
this one this is probably the most
challenging example because it involves
a fraction as well as a negative okay so
what would you do on this one what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to
subtract 5 like I normally do okay just
to get the constant out of the way on
the other side of the equation so now we
have negative 1/4 x squared minus 2x I'm
gonna factor off the negative 1/4
okay now here's the thing when you
factor out okay something it's like
dividing it out right and so what you
have to do on the inside of the
parenthesis here is you have to multiply
by the reciprocal okay so here because I
divided out negative 1/4 I'm going to
multiply it by negative 4 and so that's
going to give me
x squared plus a tax now if you want to
check your work go ahead and distribute
the negative one-fourth in you see that
gives us back negative 1/4 x squared it
also gives us back negative 2x here's
where we complete the square B divided
by 2 squared so 8 divided by 2 is 4 4
squared is 16 so do I add 16 to the left
no because remember it's negative 1/4
times 16 I actually subtracted 4 from
the right side because that's a negative
4 so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to subtract 4 from the left side as well
to keep this balanced so we have Y minus
9 equals negative 1/4 and now I'm just
going to factor this it's going to be X
plus 4 the quantity squared remember
it's half of this B value if who is
minus 8x I would write minus 4 and then
the last step is just to add the 9 to
the other side so our final result is
going to be y equals a negative 1/4 X
plus 4 squared plus 9 and our vertex is
going to be negative 4 positive 9 notice
the a value is negative that means it's
opening down the 1/4 is gonna compress
it so it's gonna be like a little bit
wider like that if you want to see how
to solve equations by completing the
square
check out the video I did right there
I'll see over in that video